hey guys Pete here today will pick up on
the problems in Game of Thrones Season
eight series last time we talked about
the problems with the night king story
and today we'll talk about the Iron
Throne I decided to do this problem
series because the ending is difficult
to figure out for a number of different
reasons focusing on problems as a way to
work through it it's not a series saying
that Game of Thrones Season 8 will be
bad because of this and this and this
actually I'm rooting for the end of the
series to be good and I think it will be
but when trying to sift through all the
textual evidence in the books and what
we've seen in the show so far I find it
hard to see what that good ending
actually looks like a big part of why I
keep running into problems is because we
don't expect the ending to be
predictable the bar has been set pretty
high with strong character development
that has us all plugged in but there's
also quite a lot that fits into common
recurring literary devices for instance
one of the main characters grew up as a
bastard boy who didn't know who his real
parents were he's gone off to live a
life of service protecting mankind
against the threat that they forgot
actually exists turns out said bastard
is actually the heir to the throne with
an impressive bloodline and that threat
that had disappeared for thousands of
years is actually on humanity's doorstep
trying to get in now he's primed for a
hero's journey and that has problems
that we'll discuss in a different video
sometime this week but you get the
picture we have a story that isn't
supposed to be that same fantasy story
but happens to have all the elements of
that fantasy story this presents
problems and let's jump into looking at
the ones that the iron throne itself
presents as we all know the iron throne
is the seat of the king or currently the
queen of the Seven Kingdoms of Westeros
the political intrigue and jockeying for
power around the throne is where we get
the name Game of Thrones for the series
one of the first aha moments you get
reading the books is that wait a minute
everyone is focused on the iron
but the story is really about the threat
of the White Walkers
who is the king isn't really going to
matter when everyone is fighting to
survive this is sort of true but then
you realize that as I said in my last
video the living will triumph over the
dead that means that life has to go on
after the war for the dawn and that
means that the Iron Throne is a factor
in the end of the story as we near the
end of the TV series it's clear that the
throne might not be the most important
thing at the beginning of season 8 but
it is still very important this is the
first problem with the Iron Throne that
it isn't a point of focus for the
characters who are most likely to sit on
it right now the battle what's the night
King and the White Walkers is and should
be the only thing John Daenerys are
thinking about as far as they know
Cersei is on their side in this battle
which means the whole idea of the crown
of the throne is out of the picture when
Jaime arrives in the north they'll find
out about her double-cross but at that
point it's gonna be too late to really
change anything this really hit me as a
problem when I watched the trailer for
the first time the season 8 trailer we
have this existential threat of the
White Walkers and the army of the Dead
and the power of the throne is still so
compelling that Cersei is basically
double-crossing Humanity in order to
hold on to her seat in a way it's hard
to imagine but at the same time you can
kind of see where she's coming from she
really has nothing left if she doesn't
have the Iron Throne
this leads into the second major problem
and that is the power of the throne and
the system itself obviously watching
this series are reading the books or
however you came across the story you
realize that it's not a pro monarchy
kind of piece it isn't saying like look
at this great system of government they
have place in this world you know it's
definitely got problems as long as there
is a throne there will always be people
who are trying to get ahead in that
system and there are always be struggles
for power you could see that in the
history of Westeros and with all the
secession problems that have happened
and all the war and pain and suffering
that's been taking place since this
series started I'm not sure if the show
really points it out as much
it's definitely there it's hinted at but
the small folk have been suffering
tremendously since the war of the five
kings so just to make sure we're on the
same page here this is definitely not a
pro war kind of story
and it's definitely not a pro absolute
monarchy kind of story
so on the one hand we agree that the
throne is important but on the other
hand we can also agree that what it
represents is not a good system of
government when I first really got into
reading theories and you know just sort
of engaging in the fandom around the
Song of Ice and Fire
there was a theory that was popular I
would say it was popular that tyrion
would help to install a democracy and
I'm not sure if it's still popular or if
it you know really is the way people
think things are gonna turn out but it
is a sort of natural conclusion when you
see how the story points out all the
flaws in this system as I mentioned
earlier you know you kind of get that
idea when you're reading that the throne
doesn't matter at all because in the end
it just won't be that important and my
10 things that have to happen in order
to make this series end successfully
video I talked about though that we do
need to understand that there is a
government in place when things are done
and that starts with the Iron Throne but
when there's an iron throne there will
always be some sort of a game of Thrones
that goes along with that and that leads
us into the next problem and that is
that none of the characters who might
end up on the throne necessarily seem
like they would be the right candidate
now I know that george RR martin has
said when talking about the end of the
series and how he knows what he knows
about the end of the series like what he
told the showrunners he said directly i
know who will sit on the Iron Throne I'm
not sure if that is to mislead us as he
used to mislead us but if you take it at
face value he says that someone will
actually be sitting on it when the story
comes to an end
since we're expecting some kind of a
subversion of the whole hero's journey
it makes it really hard to figure out
how that plays out of course we have
Daenerys Targaryen and she has
trajectory that she believes ends with
her sitting on the Iron Throne at the
end taking back what's hers by her
birthright but we actually know that she
is not the legitimate heir now that John
would be neither one of these characters
are necessarily the right fit because
this story is told in a way that really
makes it relatable and great in my
opinion all of these characters have
their problems there's really no one
thing that you could say is like hey
okay well that makes sense if that
person ends up sitting on the throne at
the end of the series I'll feel good
about the way life will carry on in the
Seven Kingdoms
after that all that leads me to believe
that Westeros will be changed I mean
they're in this battle the war for the
dawn it will definitely be changed as a
result of that but how do we get to the
point where we're like okay this makes
sense changing the system of government
it sounds like a good idea at first but
then you know say that out loud you know
that it ends with democracy being put in
place like does that really sound like a
awesome ending not exactly you might
like to believe that the people would be
more involved and that that does sound
more realistic right something that
could work but if you think about it
beyond that you know what has happened
in any of the characters stories that
really puts them into place to get that
going
obviously Daenerys had good intentions
whenever she ruled obviously John has
made some good decisions as far as doing
things for the right reasons
but there's really no situation where
either one of those people rule in a
vacuum and everything that they want to
have happen all their good intentions
play out and I will do problems with
each of those characters individually in
this series later on well I look at that
more directly but it is a big problem
this is the way the show has set up
conflict leading into this hidden battle
with the dead and in order for the story
to come full circle we have to feel good
about what might happen in the future
the last book of the series which will
hopefully get at some point is called a
dream of spring so what is a dream of
spring
actually look like also I'm not
overlooking the fact that we have pretty
good evidence that King's Landing is
going to take a hit if not be destroyed
as a result of what comes after the war
for the dawn of course Daenerys saw the
throne room destroyed in her house of
undying vision and also bran saw that
again later on when he was in the
weirwood net so that probably is going
to happen I guess if we take those
scenes literally though the throne is
actually there whoever's left alive to
sit on the throne could melt it down and
pass on some new form of government but
it's just really kind of difficult to
see where the show is taking us do you
think that any of the characters in the
story now would be a good fit for the
Iron Throne in the system that we have
or do you think that that system has to
be changed in order for us to have a
satisfied ending I do think that things
will be changed I think that part won't
be that difficult obviously don't think
Cersei can remain on the throne I fear
that she is irredeemable at this point
but I don't know who will survive I've
made my predictions about that and I
don't think it really works if you just
put the hero on the throne and call it a
day
like I think there has to be something
much more interesting up George RR
Martin's sleeve and I'll leave it to you
guys to tell me what you think let me
know in the comments whether you see
problems what you think a good solution
might be and really anything you're
thinking about as far as we lead up to
this because I think we're about three
weeks out now we're getting pretty close
so it's getting pretty exciting the next
part in this series will be coming soon
it'll probably be about John or Daenerys
I have a couple other ones lined up too
so make sure you check back if you want
to follow along with the series or with
Season eight you know what to do thanks
for watching I'll talk to you soon